determinar si 380 es divisible entre 2 3
4 5 6 9 o 10 es decir está en esta
ocasión no vamos a considerar al 7 y al
8 empecemos con el 2 entonces vamos a
hacer la pregunta si es divisible en 3 2
entonces para que un número sea
divisible entre 2 tiene que ser par es
decir si el dígito de las unidades tiene
que ser 0 2 468 entonces 380
pues su dígito de las unidades este que
está aquí es cero por lo tanto este
número es par es decir 380 es pagar
y entonces es divisible
entre 2
exactamente
ahora vamos con el 3
vamos a hacernos la pregunta si es
divisible entre 3
muy bien entonces para que un número sea
divisible entre 3 lo que tengo que hacer
es sumar sus dígitos y si el resultado
es divisible entre 3 entonces es el
número es divisible entre 3 es decir
tomar el 3 sumar del 8 y sumar el 0 esto
es igual a tres más
8 es igual a 11 más 0 pues nos quedamos
con 11 y el 11 no es divisible entre 3 y
si tengo dudas pues vuelvo a aplicar el
mismo procedimiento es decir uno más uno
es igual a dos y este resultado tampoco
es divisible entre 3 entonces a ver
vamos a vamos a marcar los puntos este
no me gusta vamos a marcarlo
este y este estos de aquí que obtuve no
son
y visibles
entre 3 al 3 lo vamos a tacharlo muy
bien ahora vamos con el 4 tal vez vamos
a preguntarnos será divisible entre 4
entonces lo primero que voy a ver voy a
escribir aquí el 380 otra vez y lo que
tendríamos que revisar es los dos
dígitos que están aquí o sea las
unidades y las decenas porque porque las
centenas siempre las centenas son
divisibles entre cuatro entonces esa
parte no tenemos que preocuparnos y solo
tenemos que preocuparnos por el número
que está formado por las dos primeras
posiciones las unidades y las decenas
entonces en este caso
el 80
pues el 80 efectivamente es divisible
entre 4 porque 4 por 2 son 8 y 4 por 20
son 80 entonces a ver pero vamos a
escribir lo que dijimos y estas dos
cifras serán divisibles entre 4
ya vimos claros pues este sexy
y entonces 80 sí
divisible
entre 4
y entonces ya estamos esto es esto es
correcto entonces ahora vamos a marcar
el 4 si funciona
pero necesito hacer un poco de espacio
entonces a ver vamos a mover nuestra
pantalla
y vamos a mover la mejor para acá vamos
a mover para acá ahí estamos muy bien
este espacio suficiente ahí estamos muy
bien
ahora vamos a revisar el caso del 5 es
decir que será divisible entre 5 para
hacer esto vamos a ver los múltiplos de
5 es decir como son los múltiplos de 5
entonces tenemos 5 tenemos 10 15 20 25
30 y en fin así podría ellos seguir muy
lejos y observamos que los múltiplos de
5 tienen un patrón si vemos la posición
de las unidades en ellas se va
alternando el patrón 5 050 es decir en
las unidades siempre los múltiplos de 5
tienen un 5 o un 0 y en nuestro caso 380
380 si tiene un cero en las unidades por
lo tanto si es divisible entre 5
perfecto entonces ahora vamos a
indicarlo aquí ahora vamos con el caso
del 6 ya ver vamos a buscar un color
para el 6 un 11 este está bueno entonces
el caso del 6 de acuerdo para este caso
lo que vamos a observar es que 6 es
igual a 3 por 2
es decir los números que sean divisibles
entre 6 tendrán que ser divisibles entre
3 y entre 2 simultáneamente y si
observamos en lo que llevamos hasta
ahorita trabajando pues el 380 es
divisible entre 2 pero no entre 3
por lo tanto no es divisible entre 6 y
esta vez lo vamos a tachar
ahora vamos con el 9
ok entonces primero nos hacemos la
pregunta si es divisible entre 9 y para
este caso vamos a utilizar una técnica
muy similar como la que hicimos en el
caso del 6 es decir el 9 lo puedo
escribir como 3 por 3 y entonces los
números que sean divisibles entre 9
tendrán que ser divisibles entre 3 y de
hecho dos veces divisibles entre 3 hay
otra técnica también muy útil que es
similar a la que estamos usando para el
3 que es yo tomo el número sumo sus
dígitos y si el resultado es divisible
entre 9 el número es divisible entre 9
es decir tomo el 3 le sumó el 8 le sumó
el 0 y entonces 3 + 8 es 11 bueno porque
el 0 no cuenta y 11 pues no es divisible
entre 9
este de aquí no es divisible entre 9
entonces también tenemos el 9
vamos ahora con el caso del 10 el caso
del 10 es de los más fáciles qué es lo
que vamos a observar cómo son los
múltiplos de 10 entonces los múltiplos
de 10 son 10 20 30 40
50 60 y en fin podría seguir larga está
lista
todos los múltiplos de 10 tienen 0 en la
posición de las unidades por lo que 380
que es nuestro número tiene un cero en
la posición de las unidades y si es
divisible entre 10 con esto terminamos